here now go ahead and go ahead and
it's okay you know here
we're just getting dolled up for the Pod
I can't do this I cannot do this this is
the mo so do you all have a like a craft
store this is like they're roommates uh
we're we're roommates we're roommates
for the last 20 years
and our parents were actually brother
and sister yeah and I'm Janine Johnson
and I am Deborah or what was it I don't
know Steve a fuck Pam
and I'm high
Pam Hollins yeah and she's High work at
what Hallmark store or you manage and
Things Remembered I manage The Things
Remembered in Franklin Tennessee and you
can't spell so all the Engravings are
wrong and you ruin everyone's urn
by misspelling their mom's name Janine
Johnson we don't even know what an urn
is because you've never earned anything
any money we never earned anything and
we're here to podcast and party and tear
some shit up
so Chelsea Lynn AKA Thea Vaughn
Thea Theodora Theodora Von wait no
Theodore Vons oh my gosh grocery store
the Walmart version
y'all uh uh these wigs are where did you
purchase did you purchase these wigs at
a Shell station
um Amazon even fancier Amazon yeah so I
what was the Google the search was it
totally go back was it cool looking wigs
yeah I think I put in Coolidge too cool
I really do think I put in cool ways can
we okay there's a couple things uh I do
I am obsessed with names of wig stores
and weave stores because in Los Angeles
Pat I don't know if you ever saw this it
was on Fairfax south of Olympic for
about
the first 12 years I lived here there
was a
it was called
Believe It or Not whoa weave store and
talent agency damn they can do a lot
that's awesome dude and I was like if I
ever get like successful oh I'm gonna
ask them to represent me and I want to
be like there I want to be like
seriously like 100 I went back I was
like driving to the airport I was like
fuck Believe It or Not Italian agency
it's time for me to switch to them yeah
I think it was when the uh all the
writers we we had to fire our agents
because the packaging stuff and I was
like oh I'm gonna hire them back how
funny and or maybe just during the
pandemic when there's no work and they
were closed oh that's awful that didn't
help but think if I just had maybe come
a little sooner they'd still be open I
wonder what they're doing now lots of
things closed Paige you look like first
of all we need the mic down a little
lower because all I'm seeing is win I
see eyes and just
um
what had um Adam Sandler
names of wig storms
you know like Kristen Wiig I like it
when it's just Wigs Wigs I like cool
wigs cool wigs my grandma's nickname was
wig have a chill still chill with chill
Wigs Wigs de glamor D apostrophe that's
good fancy fancy yeah wigs fancy wigs
fancy wigs Incorporated it has to be
incorporated you have to have an
official I feel like fancy wigs has to
have like a fancy wigs good wigs I like
fancy good wigs decent wigs
very good you know those wigs that just
freaking you pull on them like that and
they just all come out no decent wigs
like uh wigs uh you know when you have
like a disposable phone or like
something that's like uh you know
disposable phones
disposable Foods
but is that doesn't mean it's disposable
that's messy we're not cheap no
disposable Vape okay that's what's a
burner phone Pat you mean for like side
bay or whatever every time every guy I
date I'm texting is burner phone so what
have I even texting
yeah what if I'm in and I pay for the
burner
but a burner phone you don't get rid of
it you bring it back to the store no you
you pay for it in cash and it's not on a
monthly account so your name isn't
attached to it it just has minutes and
data attached to it okay a TracFone oh
yeah TracFone from Walmart
poor I grew up with a TracFone
extract the name of the branch yes well
I had a pager oh so you think you were
fucking yeah
because you would get paged and then you
would have to call them from a pay phone
oh yeah no so you were Rich that was
like 70. you're talking to someone no no
no no no no no
seven page don't well when was it by the
way you've got real confidence since you
were on this podcast last last night she
was just this quiet little thing she was
puking she couldn't she was sick I know
and a lot a lot of the comments said oh
they didn't let her talk she was really
sick the whole time so well honestly I
also didn't like to talk hey no ducky
Honestly though I uh I'm not I wasn't
even supposed to be on the podcast yeah
okay so the last one that was the 100th
anniversary episode and it was Chelsea's
birthday yeah and I kind of thought you
were her like make a wish okay I thought
you had cancer oh and I did
so thanks
well apparently we all have cancer oh
yeah we're always beating it it's just
lurking scorpions
yeah but let me ask okay so then I kind
of said I didn't know you that well and
Chelsea had been on the podcast solo uh
Chelsea's first appearance she was
wearing a Marilyn Manson shirt two days
after the alligator no one told
you it hadn't hit your feet what we're
trying not to talk about that but I was
hoping you wouldn't bring that up I
can't not because
yeah it's you know what yeah why do I
have to stop liking good music yeah and
throw away look because somebody killed
somebody no I no one died no one died
wait what they were asleep whoa they
were petite more that means Little Death
orgasm at least they came no don't even
know what's going on my dad okay growing
up we DC Redskins fans okay every photo
of me and my deceased father he's in a
Redskins shirt I'm in a Redskins shirt
not allowed to put it on Facebook
commanders oh my God I don't even know
what's going on with the with that team
what do you mean
wait what was it again Commanders
no the Redskins the Washington Redskins
oh okay okay well if it's an old photo
but you know but but you never know they
could Photoshop a new face you know what
I scribble it out and I change the red
to the uh number four the four skins and
then they'll be like that's fine baby
dicks is fine Redskins no that's okay
but the owner is a dick so you know but
it's like so shirts that have I'm not
sure I have Redskins shirts that my dad
wore yeah you know yeah you're allowed
to wear your Marilyn Manson shirt and
had Betty White on it and that's what
that angel saved it uh-huh that angel
saved him but it was actually just my
favorite I say it all the time you went
I won thank you I wouldn't thank you I
knew this was the day I was getting
canceled I knew it like you were already
on the fence about doing my podcast
and it was the day yeah good times this
is my third time here third time here
second time last time we did like a
mukbang that went wild oh man and yeah
sorry for puking what had you drank a
bacon what do you think what was that
made you puke because that made you eat
sushi pussy I did not eat all day and
then I hopped on that podcast without
eating still so
that mixed with the bacon it was weird
what you were wearing shorts you know
when you can tell someone's been wearing
the same shorts for a while I was like
if she doesn't change shorts she like to
this is not the day if she hasn't
changed shorts she has an eight she
hasn't you know when like the back of
short shorts on girls that are cotton
looks like full diapers like saggy yeah
I was like she's had a day oh I could
have been on my period I wear those big
pads you don't wear tampons my blades
how about that isn't that some shit what
do you mean isn't that wild what do you
mean because I have a bunch of clots uh
and they come the tampon the clots push
out the tampon so it's kind of like why
would you want clots and a tampon
sitting in your pad just the clock can I
blow your mind oh God the kind of
gynecologist that was
um shortly after she gave me this
incredible uh advice uh lost her license
uh for a different reason but said if
you want to get your period to go faster
like if you have a vacation coming up or
like just you know want to be a
civilized human that doesn't free bleed
um on people uh you get in a bat you put
a tampon in get in the bathtub let it
fill up pull the tampon out stand up put
another tampon in get in the bathtub
soak do it like six or seven times in
your p and you get it out faster you get
the blood out because you get in the uh
the hot water it expands
pulls out the uterine lining and you get
your period knocked out in like two days
I've always wondered if a turkey baster
would work now that's for abortions oh
that's a different thing
[Applause]
but also you
you can get it out faster because also
you know like the beginning of your
period in the end the book ends where
it's just like black tar yes and you're
like I don't want to ruin my yeah these
new jockey fucking fancy underwear yeah
I don't remember my umbros in your case
yeah yeah like you do dress like a um
like a Romanian soccer player me yeah
you look like one of the kids from
stranger things at all times I can see
that so now that you say that I just
you're so serious whatever you're very
like
um Eastern European in your aesthetic
and this is a compliment it's a
compliment yeah so I mean if you were
like a like a 24 hour internet cafe like
right outside Istanbul I feel like you
would be on a computer
yeah you don't wait in line because
you've got you've got your own desk yeah
you've got a Dell
okay yeah like one of the people that
sits up at the like you know when you go
to internet cafe or used to there was
like seats
you know I mean desks and then there was
like the ones up in the high stool with
like a just oh next to the window yeah
yeah that was you yeah oh I feel like
you were up against the window damn like
a tablet I actually like sitting on the
floor well and you're half Chinese so
maybe that has something to do with it
are you half Chinese yeah so do you know
uh Chinese what area of China because
it's a huge fucking place yeah we are
Cantonese so I have a difference
did you make did your ancestors make
covid or not well you know what I think
uh the news did but uh
your answers made the machines the news
is delivered onto it shit uh yeah I'm
not sure but all I heard was China so I
guess they did it but was it from a bat
we still don't even know I don't know it
was luck
bats have gotten fucked dude it's like
you know when you look at certain things
that got fucked like sharks bats it's so
because in history they've been already
so used as like vampires it's an easy
thing to Peg on yeah it was a bat the
bat yeah and people will believe it and
they'll believe it bats are the nicest
little animals they're sweet little
um and they get blown up uh in fact they
eat bugs if it was not for bats we would
be so we would all have malaria like
they eat the bugs that cause disease
we'd have less Nile on everything I'm
not saying it wasn't from bad I don't
fucking know what was it supposed to be
from a Pangolin I thought I don't know
what that is a penguin remember well the
first theory about kovid was um remember
when every day there was a new set of
fat you'd start from scratch you would
whatever we read we were like it came
from a bat sandwich and we're like you
know and then the next morning you'd be
like no no came from a Pangolin a wet
Market we're like that's like we didn't
go wait a second we heard something
different yesterday yeah yeah this next
thing let's not buy into it until
tomorrow morning yeah we were just so
like they're just trying shit out the
next movie was that at Wet markets in
China that the blood from the bats was
Dripping onto the pangolins and then the
pangolins made
covid okay someone ate it dude I'm still
hearing stuff I just learned that yeah I
hadn't heard that but I don't think this
was ever true but this they do in China
they traffic these things for their
scales which is really fun and Whitney
has bat um catchers I just started no no
you just made it abuse not the bad house
well I thought it was a theater well no
it's like a little house so they'll all
like get in there and chill and then
there was this bad guy on Rogan recently
and he holds them and touches them and
they're like the sweetest little guys oh
and they live for a long time oh I heard
that and they never bite or hurt humans
unless they're very scared or confused
don't have rabies well they are cute
yeah and the same thing with sharks
sharks have been like given this totally
bad rap I love sharks and I will uh cage
dive very soon we're doing it do it with
me I'm going with Eli Roth okay Eli Roth
who um you don't need a cage dive
you can Chum your whole shit they don't
want to eat anything that is not dead
fish so Paige can't go oh um that's on
you guys
so they are like um Eli rothy did a
documentary called Finn on Discovery
plus he was just on the show and they're
being slaughtered what is it they're
first of all sharks are older than trees
oh gosh yeah they like to use they like
to sell
um the fans slaughter them because
they've been so uh we've been so
conditional believe that they live a
fucking evil but if we don't have sharks
we're gonna have so much uh overtake of
algae and there's gonna be no oxygen
emotions
I'm planning a trip because I want to
raise awareness of like you know because
also there's something called squalene
which is comes from sharks yeah for your
skin so you can do it plant-based and
it's like squalling you know what I mean
so it's like where are we going
I'll ask him okay okay do you know how
to open a so the only fan so okay so I
am now uh a part of the only fans family
I am the uh what would you call me what
would I what what uh
what member of the family am I I would
say head bitch start of the head yeah
you're the head of the snake I've never
had a family before guys what would this
relative be you're the you're the head
of the snake like I feel like
um and uh because and by the way you
guys inspired me a lot with only because
I watched what you guys made so Tammy
bangs the show that by the way I am off
for television shows all the time I say
no okay I all when I tell you you
finally get to a point in your career
where you get an incoming call where
someone's like your hero wants you to
star in their television show 10
episodes seven months of work and then
I'm like I can't live in Albuquerque for
eight I can't I love it there you guys I
have dogs I have
I make an outgoing call to Chelsea going
I want to be in your show Tammy bangs on
only fans where you play she plays a
porn Empire bitch head bitch of porn
Okay I said I would like to play a porn
star yeah okay yeah I'll show my tits
okay yes and you did say that I was like
I got Stamos
Stamos is in John Stamos is a fan of
yours dead me Stamos both topless she's
like yeah let me think about it oh no
not at all no there's no way not at all
no no and then we had a date down and
then you were like we have to reschedule
I'm like dude fuck it did Aubry Plaza do
it here's what happened you told me that
if Katherine Han if you shot if no no no
no here's what happened after you told
me that we had a shoot and I didn't ask
you because I was like I don't want to
bother her I know she's busy maybe she
was just telling me that but I don't
think you would ever bought it and Men
because I'm that way and then we'll fix
it I I know and you see how busy we see
how you were out yeah no I'm not busy
for the people I love and number one and
number two
um uh what have I ever not I mean no no
no and then the Same by the way someone
runs my social media sometimes I look
like way busier than I am okay that's
good to know and then we did book and
then we had to reschedule something and
then you had to show them I can't even
remember yes you can no no I can't this
has been like you hear me out I got
fired no I literally my goals like my
vision board right now
I'm gonna cry I'm dead to me it is like
the bravest funniest it's everything
I've always wanted to do like I feel
like I've been making television I like
I'm promised you're gonna be able to be
brave and funny and like do everything
you do in your stand-up and you get
there and then they tie your hands
around your back you're not allowed to
say Jesus you have to say Pepsi instead
of code because they have to deal with
them and then I go from Network to
network and then it's like I finally
fuck got this thing at Hulu that I
thought you know after Rami was there
and I was like I can like go for it and
then they got bought by Disney which is
like fine yeah but I just I I've done
I've been on this road before and I
tried to make Roseanne on ABC which is
Disney and then so I was like I just
like want to be able to make something
that I don't have to that we can just do
whatever the fuck we want to do I don't
care about like I've just made enough
shows at this point and I was like Two
Broke Girls we actually were able to do
more than most streamers now wow like
she was she said um and uh Kat Dennings
the monologue of the pilot she said
because she's a waitress and someone was
snapped at her and she came back and she
was like yeah may I help you you know
what I mean like she's yeah anyone that
was rude and she said like this makes my
vagina to dry up yeah say that you can
never say that today right right it's
weird it's almost like things are
getting more conservative YouTube is
even monetizing stuff and taking out the
algorithm and say fuck or if you even
say I think Q Anon people are if you say
curious anything
it's getting ridiculous that's why I
started that's why I started Tammy Banks
it has its own website I post on only
fans I have a picture yeah
um it's the funnest thing I do dude
y'all make me laugh truly harder than
anyone uh the only fans uh uh our boss
over only fans brought us some Dom can
you have you ever had a
uh this is this will retail at a Cheesy
nightclub for two thousand dollars
okay we could also start a bid right now
you have two choices we can have and
celebrate the fact that we are about to
lock the cut on the only fans Burke
Chrysler roast uh which
the only thing I didn't get that I
wanted
trailer trash Tammy oh play by Chelsea
Lynn I'm like December 6th let's go
she's like I'm in Mexico I literally was
like I was about to call Greg and go can
I pay to move the trip oh but I know how
bad how hard you've been working and I
know you need to go on that trip yeah so
you better have come 40 times a day I it
was my friend's 30th birthday and we had
it planned for a while dude I will be at
the next one are you you will I know
it's I'm so glad that you did that
because y'all are so like successful on
only fans and I want to understand like
your journey about it I'm on it I feel
like I'm never going back to any other
network oh hell yeah the fact that you
can go direct to the people without
network notes yeah bullshit you can get
direct feedback from them I think is I'm
happy to take notes I just wanted to
come from the people that actually
watched the shop yeah yeah that makes
sense exactly you can't say some words
which it's like come on now on what only
on only fans you can't say poop poop
p-e-e or the other word p o o but
okay those are three but come on but I
think that might be more than other
cultures or languages that mean
something different than we think this
show is brought to you by better help
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding because
sometimes like
or why we react the way that we react
until we like talk through things okay
better help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can take you on that
journey of self-discovery from wherever
you are discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com Whitney
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help help.com slash
Whitney I was struggling with a lot of
sadness last week and it was coming out
as anger and I didn't catch it I took a
week off from from therapy and stuff
really hit the fan therapists are there
to go come dump on us so you don't harm
your other relationships while trying to
solve a problem that's already hard I
made that mistake this week and you
can't stay clean on the shower you took
yesterday you know and I did that I went
I'm I talk about therapy all the time
I'm I tell people they need to do this
and then I went but I don't need to do
it this week because I I I'm the queen
of mental health so do as I say not as I
do
I love you guys betterhelp.com
all right so you can't say pee poop or
poo poo yeah pretty much no one should
say that in general though do we well
she says it a lot but why don't you say
just shit give me a con give me an
example well I wanted to start just like
a little segment that I used to do on
Snapchat called pooping with Paige where
I just talk and like I'm not actually
gonna be shitting but I just want to
wake up early in the morning
sit on the toilet with my fucked up hair
why don't you call it the funniest shit
I've read in a while is when um since
y'all stayed in my house last night and
I was texting Chelsea uh can you let my
dog out or you were on the Chain too and
she said uh does he need to go pop pot
p-o-t space p-o-t that's what I say to
my dogs an eagle pop pot Lego putt-pot
yeah what what people say to get their
dogs because they've done it alone for
years and then you hang out with them or
like time to go potty poop
yes but they have to do it why don't you
do pop pop yeah and then and then I got
my smoking pot and you're sharing pot
with Paige yeah you're smoking pot and
you're on the pot
I was thinking when you that's talking
with me I'm just saying whenever there's
a limitation that always means there's a
more creative fix that's you know what I
mean yeah because pooping with Paige is
like people are gonna go I know what
that is look how cute and then yeah well
it's just because I was already doing it
so like people would get it but yeah but
Paul was paid you know it's great yeah
and then it can involve just to other
smoking yeah token and yeah shit maybe
that's good you shit every more I don't
think oh every day I know first every
day but like is that I feel like guys
shit when they wake up it just depends
how much I've ate the previous day yeah
you're supposed to have uh three sheds a
day oh I do more I do three shifts
before noon I'm not kidding she has
Little Squirts though so would it be
well there's I take probiotics and stuff
so it's it's uh it's healthy well the
card kombucha the June Shine the our
heart kombucha dude it's like a beer
shit of your life the next day it was
it's like giving birth okay it's like
it's like evil comes out of your body
whoa I need a good cleanse yeah you're
like is that gum like it's so it gets
everything great yeah it's good to know
yep you need a good time the night
before okay done and have you ever taken
aloe pills no no one aloe vera yeah okay
okay so be careful do not do this more
than once like
um if you're constipated or you're just
like like if I've like been traveling a
lot and I just feel like I've been
eating the and I'm just not like on
point although I'm a grapes not bitch
all day long grape nuts did I say grapes
not grapes you say grapes not is that
the stuff at Costco it's the old person
cereal why is everything about Costco
with you no that first time no it's not
you brought a Costco or oh that was your
only fans guy he brought up okay yeah
yeah wrong dude yeah yeah
I love grape nuts grape nuts are but you
gotta let them soak yeah okay here's my
deal with my favorite thing to do is in
the winter months you get some eggnog
put it over grape nuts let it soak for
like 20 minutes
whoa put them in ice cream do I mean and
let it melt frozen yogurt and then the
next day you that's like 12 pounds
lighter wow okay one aloe pill
you have to like cancel you can't have
plans for like three days oh you old
shit your brains out but it's like it's
a um
that is pushing it we like to go to
Applebee's and to be honest we're never
constipated but it's shit from no no
this is shit you've been carrying around
like for a year they say we were
carrying around what like five pounds of
shit at all times that's like old that's
like hardened in there and it so this is
like cold whatever it does you'll think
you'll shit seven times two days later
you're still like I don't even know
where it's all coming from
it's like ancient shit when's a good
time to do it like when you feel sick or
do it like when you just feel like if
you've been sometimes when I'm like
traveling a lot or International
traveling I feel like the plane don't
you get a little bit like weird after a
plane yeah you'll have those like rabbit
shits that are kind of weird like my
nose hasn't stopped running I have
allergies since we've been here oh at my
house just when we land in California we
both do you always have have you always
had I don't have allergies
why did you just say we both have it
because she said you said you were
feeling allergies you were sneezing you
sneezed like 15 times do you remember
oh boy maybe I did yeah
and then you're like dude my allergies
are are bad can I say something when
people start spending a lot of time
together they do like you probably
thought that oh no
oh big time I could have said it are you
guys starting to merge into the same
person dude is the weirdest thing look
at us but also okay well this is only a
three years old relationship yeah okay
first time I met like since
the last time I saw you I don't know
where you end and you began I it's very
unclear but we don't scissor for by
watching we've never done that we're
just friends I don't picture I can't see
I would smother her with my no scissors
huh
no I'm looking at you no no scissoring
is hold on Pat Pat hold on I'll look it
up if I just put my veg anywhere near
her it would it would eat her a lot
scissoring you're not on top of the
other person I think he's dry humping uh
uh no you're so scissoring there's no
fucking my algorithm so what were we
talking about like will you open it
let's have let's have the dawn parents
alone okay um because we're celebrating
all sorts of shit okay I'm this is I
looked up scissoring PornHub didn't even
come up a website called
xnxx.com fabric store PornHub
what is it that'd be great if it was
what if Michael's okay that's not
scissoring hold on I feel like this is
confusing me huh I I'm really at a loss
of how to talk about Etsy because I'm
it's my whole life
etsy's my whole life the the this whole
podcast studio is decorated by Etsy look
some people call me a hoarder
I believe I'm a collector
um the things that mean the most to me
are things that I've ordered off of Etsy
Etsy sellers have everything from
statement pieces to rugs sofas daily
Staples they also have outerwear and
accessories like it's not just
um you know people making goldfish bowls
out of vintage doll heads anymore like
there is that that's my that's my
favorite corner of etsy is the weird
wild Oddities you know but it's also
where I get my underwear I get my toilet
paper off Etsy at this point I get my uh
lotion
um I get perfume I get uh my hair
products everything
you can shop jackets jewelry Furniture
art and more made for all budget in
every occasion are you new to Etsy use
the code new for 10 off your first
purchase that's code new maximum
discount value of 50 offer ends June
30th 2023 see terms at etsy.com terms
for home style and gifts shop etsy.com
Etsy has it did you ever think you were
a lesbian I like once a month I'm like
I'm gay well I people always assumed
that I was me too because I played
softball in college and I'm almost six
foot tall I'm very large wait no but
I've always come off as a little Butch
especially in my early 20s especially
what'd I say
well they say that's not a word
we just make up you don't know what I
meant yeah especially but you should do
a Tammy bangs dictionary that's yes
that's great sorry I can't be around
them and not manage I can't take special
businesses yeah but people when they
found out I was married they're like oh
like married to Greg you need to marry
someone because nobody knows you're a
lesbian dude they made house bets like
dude she's alive you know and I just
watch you watch isn't that wild you know
you've thought that about a couple
people what
growing up you know oh yeah you called
for some reason in your head yeah yeah
you know what it is like oh damn people
now they assume you're a lesbian if you
don't flirt with them
um you know yeah yeah you know what I
mean dudes yeah yeah like if I'm working
for someone for a couple years and we
didn't get drunk and hook up at the
company party like she's a lesbian I'm
like no I just don't I'm not into you
yeah if they think that that's fine fuck
them also do I look like I have the time
to put up with a woman talking
like do I seem like the type of person
that would have put up with Meandering
stories that go nowhere yeah I also had
a realization truly two nights ago or
last night it was last night Valentine's
Day where lesbian couples
it's one of the lesbians is not gay
and there are these lesbians where it's
a girl who like was got cheated on and
they're with a lesbian that's a super
high functioning handyman type lesbian
so they did it for the brain they did it
because they like fuck man I got cheated
on and they just need a soft place to
land and they need like their um their
toilet's been running
you know what I mean it's a mess and
there's like these lesbians that just
fucking are like yeah come in and save
the day yeah and and then you know
because there's these Straight girls
that like can't don't know where they
live when they're drunk you can't get
them home and a lot of lesbians like and
got straight guys love that shit yeah
like lost bird like yeah in a mess oh I
couldn't even find mine and nobody gay
for like six months and get their life
back on track and then go back again oh
my gosh that's funny it's a thing I see
all the time I have I when Susie said
that I can think of I can think of two
people girls that I know me too and I'm
from a small town yeah that happened
they just had to they they just knew a
friend would never do it yeah and a man
would never fucking be like I'm not
gonna clean up your mess after someone
just cheated on you yeah I get why he
did it you fucking mess and they're like
at their rock bottom of their drinking
problem and a lesbian's the only person
that would put up their shit because
it's like a hot chick that's like damn
you know what I mean yeah
for sure for show
um okay will you will someone open this
Pat do you want to open this or do you
know how to open champagne models to be
honest I've just always let other people
do it but I can try okay so tell me
about um okay Tammy Banks like do you
find now you're on season three do you
find like it's do you go like how do we
out do ourselves like how do we top last
season
yes yes
um I also feel like in a way yeah I also
feel like the show's so funny that it I
do think that but it also doesn't matter
because it's it's the show's so
ridiculous that I just and it's like the
office it's basically the office the
behind the scenes of like you know a
porn Empire and yeah and like only I'm
only asking that it's so stupid that I
asked that because I'm just going like
oh it's a sex show and I think as a
comic I found every special I did if I
talked about sex and squirting the next
time I'm like how do I top this and when
I go you know what I shouldn't I should
go the other direction and just go like
I'm gonna do a special that's like kind
of clean yeah yeah for sure I feel that
you got it Honeys you feel that we're
like anal what else yeah
I've never opened a champagne thing in
my life I well I think you girls have
men do this for them we don't make
drinks we don't buy drinks this is are
you scared of it I've seen a lot of
videos of women doing it oh how'd you do
that
just popped it
popped it up did you do that with my
neck next time
that sounds great
by the way you know that you know that
sex toy that I'm super into she
introduced me to it I had never I had
never used a sex toy in my life you love
it
I don't think they should be on the
market yeah okay because it is like
it is it's yeah not fair it's wild
it's the best thing in the world it is
the first time I used it I was 39 years
old
a chocolate sucker I am so glad I did
not have these a minute sooner I would
not have I would have made two specials
and be homeless yeah dude they're
amazing
yeah I was like I've never had an orca
is this if this is an org I don't know
what I no wonder I haven't thought I
thought I was gay because I was like sex
is like fine yeah masturbating is like
just takes forever I didn't even know
about that 30 seconds tops and I'm
busting
no it's like it's like it go it's you're
like I don't even know zip one out and
go about your day I didn't know this was
possible yep I forgive everyone yep
life-changing I wake up and I'm like
this person's go I'm gonna have a
talking to this what are you doing
you're like you know what you're giving
you a raise yeah I love your attitude
yep oh wow it's amazing and I've been
telling her she's to get one well you
know what I can get like doing sex very
easily I'm sorry I can get off during
sex
first I want to pour this um Dom
Perignon I don't know how to prove it to
you but uh yeah I just take my word for
the video but let me ask you has it
always been that way or is it something
that you have had to work at because
sorry so much of sex uh getting offline
is
um I could have helped out it's mental
and you have to yes oh yes the brain is
huge nothing poured I was a waitress for
like 20 seconds I got fired shocker
um I actually have fire because people
would order stuff and I'd be like this
is so cute it has a dolphin it's a shark
but it's supposed to be red wine and
then the little shark pokes out
um but I uh
oh yeah okay so the key to oh sorry
cheers to the Clint Blaster 101 yes
cheers to the clip blaster 101. it's not
called the 101.101 by the way that's the
highway Pat is it is a Highway
um Pat has been here we have been
editing the only fans roasted bird cry
shirt no one deserves Don pair none more
than Pat yes we should give him the
whole bottle it's late at night that is
truly like a goddamn Legend
um I there's something kind of special
about this also because it's like I look
at you guys and you're like creative
soul mates it's so hard to find and I
feel like
Pat and I are creative soul mates
cheers to that cheers to that so cheers
to creative first time trying expensive
Beverages and the hot guy that I have
set on my floor here we go cheers to
that
come on little buddy you're actually
he's actually so funny on champagne you
remember you came home on champ you
drank champagne once and you ordered all
that candy
damn that's my kind of at the airport
yeah he drank champagne in the airport
and like bought like you know the
airport everything's like seven times
more he came home with all this candy
from the airport the Sweet Shop I
couldn't enjoy it because I was like
this is like
forty dollars yeah oh probably more oh
yeah probably more let's before we get
trashed let's have her do the intro so
this is before Bert Kreischer comes out
before anything in the show I you know
we did The Comedy Store and before Burke
came out and Trevor Wallace hosted and
all the days came out I just said well
bird Crusher what if can you just say
what are we doing is this just audio
yeah okay but I don't think we should do
some promos with it got you and I showed
the roast to Bert yesterday and he like
loved it and freaked out and I was at
his office so I got a bunch of his
shirts I just stole that is cute I
wanted to uh okay you take that one
while he pulls this up oh wow hold on I
was gonna do one I thought that's funny
with um
to cut the nipples out of the tits out
of one oh yes you can like make a tank
top out of it no problem I got a couple
thank you so much oh hold on it was
close perfect oh this is the something's
burning oh that's cute so I got a bunch
I stole a bunch of his merch
um so okay he's about to pull it up and
basically it's just like
ladies and gentlemen it's like I feel
like that's so weird now you want me to
do it as Tammy I used to say yes sir and
yes if I didn't say yes sir yes ma'am my
aunt would smack me upside the head okay
I have said yes sir and yes ma'am my
whole life now I say yes sir and yes
ma'am people like you can't I you know
it's just gender yeah yeah and you're
like
that was polite like two years ago yeah
yeah I I say bless you and then I'm like
oh shit I think we do oh yeah and then
you'll introduce Trevor okay
I'm saying it as Tammy yes everybody
ready yes
[Laughter]
I didn't want to pop off oh you're gonna
die
I'll read it a couple times read it a
couple times ready you can use my phone
and airdrop it to yourself okay well
then we're getting it here that's nice
of you oh yeah okay no we have seven
cameras here what do you think well you
know sometimes it's different it's audio
it's this right okay
welcome to the let me start
I don't have the hair back
okay I want to make it right do you want
me to show it to you what you're what
you're about no you told you I saw it
before Oh that's what I think it is
awesome yes ready
welcome to the only fans TV roast of
Bert Kreischer can you do one where you
say Chrysler I was about to do it okay I
was gonna do it I don't know if you want
okay trust your gut
welcome to the only fans TV roast of
Burt Chrysler
and our host for the evening Trevor
Wallace I think we should uh wow uh I
think and for your host or is it our
host well he's our he's he's everybody's
host
and your host for the evening or keep it
going for our hosts
Wallace okay I love that okay it's so
dumb
welcome to the only fans TV roast of
Burt Chrysler
and your host for the evening give it up
for Travis Wallace
Travis that's great that felt good
Travis Wallace that's so stupid
I love dumb shit do you uh your podcast
you guys start a podcast since the last
time you're on my podcast you came on
mine and were like well if she can do
this we can do it yeah
this makes money yeah did I inspire you
guys we just have to talk okay yeah
we'll just sit there and talk and then
what did you like did you put any
thought in I don't as you can tell where
you're like this is what we're gonna do
did you go through a couple iterations
oh yeah segments and we wanted callers
and we got it down we have segments at
the top and then and then it's really
all collar driven and we get on average
about 5 000 voicemails a week and we go
through and we pick uh voicemails to
play each episode and we riff off of we
answer those questions we listen people
calling with wild stories I mean some of
the shit you I mean I'm curious do you
ever do them live like have them call
live no we've tried we have troubles to
freeze up we've tried yes that's exactly
what our first experience was just not
good yeah and people won't answer it's
very weird so I was like we're not well
I think we forget like that we're
performers we've been doing a lot and
then people call in and then they get
embarrassed or they get scared or they
kind of like freeze up and then we feel
like bullies oh yeah are they trying to
be funny we have great colors though oh
yeah I just mean but when someone's on
the spot like it always kind of go and
then you don't want to be mean so it
kind of gets weird because that means
people always ask me like when I was
doing Instagram lives I would love to
like like you surprise people and bring
them on sometimes they wouldn't won't
even show their face they're so nervous
yeah yeah but then sometimes it's
someone that it's like you know they
didn't know they were gonna be picked
and you pick them and then they try to
be funny and then you kind of like oh
yeah you can't make fun of them but it's
also your like feel bad for them it's
just like tricky yeah yeah sometimes
it's hard to come Comfort people who are
so nervous yeah and it's like I think
you all I mean also as a con there I get
nervous yeah like I still get nervous
like how could you know it's like you
know when I go on other people's
podcasts if Mom's like why am I so like
I want an h3h3
um and it was a live one and I know them
I'm friends with them and I just like
got nervous I don't know and I was like
this is crazy like I I get nervous for
pods too not yours because I I've been
here a few times but first time I came
up oh I was nervous yeah and and I don't
know why I don't know why we're just
sitting around talking but it can be
yeah but still when I go on Rogan I get
nervous I kind of feel like you have to
stay the night at their house the night
before like how we did we need to start
doing that whatever it's just good roll
straight into it but I do think when you
sh because also we were supposed to do
this three hours ago and then we put it
just feels like yeah you know I also
think that the better you know someone
the less nervous you're gonna be because
you also know you get to go like if I
want to cut something I can and I know
she's gonna cut out shit that's like
weird or whatever but like yeah I still
get nervous on Bobby Lee sometimes I
think also I feel like I know each
podcast's fans and I know which ones are
like Bobby and tigerbelly they have a
lot of like they talk about mental
health a lot they talk about his
sobriety so they get a lot of sensitive
people you know that are sort of like
relate to them and then if I go on and
I'm too and they're so attached to them
and Bobby and I's relationship is we
fucking rip each other apart and then I
go on his podcast and I'm ripping them
apart and people are like he's just got
sober you're gonna make him kill himself
I'm like wait what yeah you think I'm
like bullying your hero yeah but like
this is how you know what I mean so it's
like and then I don't know how to be
yeah they don't know how y'all are yeah
yeah be hungry it's like kind of weird
for sure what was a podcast that you've
done that you um
we're like ugh I didn't know like I
still go on podcasts that are my own
friends and I kind of don't know
honestly I feel like all of them
I'm not even kidding you I get nerve I
get I just get nervous I think you're I
think yours is the only pod that I
haven't gotten nervous on the last
couple times but you know what else it's
like you I think
like we kind of do like I did my first
four spot I mean my last Bachelor my
fifth special the first 20 minutes I
guess I was talking about sex like I
feel like that's what I do when I
perform but like in conversations like I
used to always go on Howard Stern and
I'm actually kind of shy about shit so
it's like you go on a podcast and
someone's like so anal squirting and
you're like whoa like I wasn't prepared
like I talk about that on stage but it's
like 11 A.M yeah for sure you know what
I mean then I'd like low blood sugar and
I'm kind of like it's daylight
absolutely oh and fans too I've been in
a dude I've been I was in Kroger and
these two girls
from Clear Acro I mean I'm talking like
clear across seven
hey your pussy stinks oh yeah and I look
over like we love we love you they just
and I'm just like oh my God you guys
yeah I mean they could I mean walk up to
me yeah which is great but I was just
kind of like oh my God you know that
people I love it fentanyl a girl came
back yesterday huh and she's like oh
gosh I wish I had a fart right now and
we're like yeah we wish you didn't yeah
it's a little bit of a trick because
like that's yeah it's like when I was
doing the roast like the first I started
doing the rose I think that's what got
people to know me and I'm like walking
to the airport and people like hey you
anorexic cunt
what I'm like I didn't even know I was
you knew me I thought this was you just
yeah you know what I mean yeah oh yeah
yeah
also these people know you and they
You've Won because you've our goal is
that they feel CL the ideas were your
friends oh true then they are yeah I
don't no I yeah I definitely didn't mean
that in a negative way I think it's you
know that the fact that they they feel
like they can walk up to us no I know
it's starting yeah no but they didn't
want she didn't walk up to you she yeah
you're right clear across but it does
take you a second because like I'll have
people like if I go on vacation or
something I'll Snapchat it I have this
one girl company you know I was in
Kroger again it happens at Kroger a lot
on vacation no no I I came back from
vacation and this lady this lady walks
up to me and she goes how was Hawaii and
it took me I was like yeah because your
mind I know her and I'm so afraid of
forgetting people are being such an
asshole that this is someone I've met
and I forgot yes oh yeah and then it
took me a minute that she was a Snapchat
I'm like oh I'm like and then I'm like
oh it was great yeah thank you so you
know like I am so fucking afraid of
being rude and not remembering someone I
had a guy show up in my house and he
goes I open the door and he goes um he
goes hey
Whitney it's you know and I went
hey I did not recognize him at all but I
was like this must be like one of the
neighbors kids and I'm like how are you
what's how sorry it was just this is out
of context how have you been yeah and he
was like wait
do you you Rec you do know me and I was
like of course I know you oh my God yes
it's just been so long how are you and
he was like
oh God I'm so sorry and then the stalker
that showed up at my house in socks and
not shoes because he worried there were
tracking devices literally was like
did you just pretend you knew me and you
didn't and I was like
oh who's crazier he called me out on
being like the fact that he's within the
first 10 seconds of thinking you're a
crazy bitch
is wild yeah
yeah
first 10 seconds he's like wait I'm
gonna turn around
he's never had anybody else creep him
out I know like I never mind he was like
have regret he's like I wish I had
stocked Allison Brie like a normal
person
you never mind codependent asshole
um I'd like watched him fall out of love
with me um I was like I was apologizing
to a guy with wearing socks and I was
like I'm so sorry I didn't mean it I
just was so worried I didn't know you
and uh that's funny oh by the way it is
very late at night sorry I keep yawning
but I I won't I don't care I won't I'm
having a blast it's just late do you
know there's a national Adderall
shortage no
someone told me this the other day this
is friends of mine this is their biggest
not Ukraine not Russia not the the kids
making the Cobalt batteries they're like
do you hear about the Adderall shortage
I'm like no because I don't take 50
milligrams of Adderall a day to be
unemployed or whatever the fuck you
don't do all day huh and food shortages
I was hearing too well this is not going
to be what is everything just sort but
no that's gonna be well there's gonna be
a fertilizer because Russia has half the
world's fertilizer I guess so we're not
gonna be able to grow food as long as
we're in this war yeah so what should we
do but can it up Pickle them yeah you
should be pickling your shit that's
smart we need to get started like now
but y'all moved to Nashville you're not
gonna have problems there no I don't
think so uh-uh I don't think so uh as
long as you shop at Kroger which it's
become obvious you do I'm there a lot
you're gonna be just fine yeah I'm there
a lot what's the best grocery store I'm
a like when I lived in Virginia it was
Food Lion oh they have okay I'm new to
Food Lions they have them in Nashville
they're excellent oh does Trader Joe's
count for something okay you know what
Trader Joe's I think is the number one
grocery store
snacks yeah the snacks and the dips yeah
very creative the pre-packaged Foods I
just feel like they've always got like a
chocolate covered pretzel with the
caramel salt like they they fuck around
and find out over there they can
unpackage like some produce you know
each individual cucumber doesn't always
have to be having a condom on it you
know yeah they put all the Persian
cucumbers in one place yeah yeah I mean
everything it's hard enough to get me to
eat a cucumber you can't shrink wrap it
yeah
I love I don't I grocery if I go if I if
I'm like hey I need to go to the grocery
store because I have nothing but I'm
gonna go to everything I will go like
four different grocery stores I'll go to
Kroger I'll go to Whole Foods I'll go to
Trader Joe's it's over for me really why
well first of all I don't like the the
way they conned Us in Whole Foods
with the Amazon food well that the
Amazon will get to that okay well first
of all they're they're bar their hot bar
which I used to live by it's canola oil
oh it's not even olive oil if you heat
it at certain temperatures it's Carson
jet yeah but it shouldn't shouldn't be
like flaxseed it shouldn't be some shit
healthy shit yeah yeah I didn't know
that it's canola oil look at the
ingredients and have you been in one of
their hot bars recently it's fucking sad
oh yeah you want to stay away from me
it's sad but I'm just saying it's cold
it's soggy like the shit that there's no
love in it yeah they're switching up
everything Reese's Peanut Butter Cups
little Debbies I mean ingredients are
just changing
Whole Foods I'm just saying you know
like the granola oils they I mean all of
our Foods just but this is not healthy
it's just more expensive it's yeah it's
changed I used to work there did you
know that no long time ago long time ago
I worked there in the bakery in Dallas
Texas oh shit Dallas how did you get
there I just I just drove there and
lived there why uh it was right after
Greg and I got married he got a job in
Dallas so we lived there oh because he
was at by the way Greg her husband is my
Hall Pass yeah the only person that I
like he is it is very rare that I meet a
married man and I'm like can we I will I
I want to be your friend and I'm not I
don't care if your wife thinks I he's
cool dude her husband is first of all he
was a Navarro dog yes went to Navarro
and you yes so you love him right there
oh you love him right there he cannot
yeah he played football there Anna Texas
he played football and so then he went
from Corsicana direct to Dallas no
Corsicana and then he went to play
football in Oklahoma at Southeastern
Oklahoma State University that's where I
met him
we technically met on Facebook and this
was like because also Greg he is unlike
anyone I've ever met he is one of one
has he always been yes he's like Leslie
Nielsen I don't he's not trying to be
funny but everything he's so sincere
yeah
I think you don't even try playing
around 24 7 though you'll get tired of
that ass real quick
I would love it you just gotta taste
I'll drop him mine
no but he's wonderful but also I think I
come from such a cynical world that he's
just this like bright he has like
sunshine but he's also he's elf yeah
he's a little Sparkle he's
I call him Sparkle he's Will Ferrell's
Elf yes he's like remember when elf
would like walked by uh welfare and it
was like the world's best coffee and
he's like you guys did it oh dude I
would do that shit I gotta bring him on
pod next time on my fourth time dude
nothing's funnier than you we okay so we
land in Vegas we get the wind sends us a
driver okay these drivers no one ever
talks to I whenever I'm like hey how's
it going man they're like yeah
everyone's such an asshole they never
speak to the driver so when I ask a
couple questions I feel like yeah he
gets in the front seat no one gets in
the front seat next to a professional
driver it's like just a known thing okay
he gets in the front he's like hey man
and he's like I love this car Denali
they let you pick your car the car you
drive the guy's like no right no like
and he's like so what's Mr wind like and
guys like you know I've never met him I
don't know him he's like oh man that's
Greg with every single person he meets
and at the end he's like oh man what's
your number if you want to hang out
while we're here literally that's how it
always and with everybody
so I mean I'm not even kidding you I
will go home okay one of his very best
friends we had just moved to San Diego
and I came home and he was like hey uh
I'm going fishing with Bill on Saturday
and I go who's Bill
he's like oh I bought this carburetor
off Craigslist and he's the guy I bought
it from we're going fishing on Saturday
it's some like old guy named Bill Bill
thinks Greg is Craig from the list
it's Craigslist and they're still best
like best friends like Greg will be like
Oh I'm going over to uh Todd and Pat's
house for dinner I'm like who's that
dude he will just I'm not kidding I
think Greg needs to do because I feel
like the hardest thing in the world I've
made that free page I feel like the
hardest thing in the world is for grown
men to make new friends
don't you think though yeah because I
think one person has to really be like
what's your number man otherwise it's
like that's great that's why guys can
only hang out at football yeah it's okay
to get guys guys guys numbers oh yeah
but just venture out there and ask for a
number and hang out sometimes you need
friends yeah I wanted to start a it was
like grinder
for bar fights so that men could huh
yeah like get a rink in there
like two miles away from you there's a
bar fight like it's so guys which is you
know what I mean that's funny just or
shit like how else are guys gonna meet
yeah there's a there's a bar fight two
blocks away let's go guys can only hang
out if they're like meeting up for like
a Dungeons and Dragons convention if
they're like at a tailgate like guys
have fashioned all these rituals to hang
out without having to get each other's
numbers yeah they're just like laying in
a bed like five guys just laying in a
bed on their phone you met on Facebook
what happened so we and this was when
Facebook like wasn't big oh you had to
have a college ID to have Facebook so
this was before like social media only
want to make sure you were under 18.
they you had to have a college ID so
anyway uh we had friends of friend we're
going to different colleges we had uh uh
you know mutual friends and he I guess
saw my picture I don't know he messaged
me and said I like your eyes they really
draw me in and I go what the fuck is
this yes with these tits that's here I
was like what a loser and I I mess it I
messaged him back and dude that was it
we've been together 16 years
16. what was your first date
Because by the way when he said that he
meant it oh yeah your eyes Drew him he
oh yeah but he's the most sincere I had
put the craziest looking filter and my
eyes were my eyes were the color of this
wall and my eyes they weren't even a
natural blue so he's so he was he's
Hitler
I got his ass
and our first date was kicking and
screaming and we wouldn't watched a Will
Ferrell movie no I thought you just
meant that I was kicking it off
screaming and then um and that was
pretty much it I um he walked me to my
car and uh he gave me a hug and I could
tell he wanted to kiss me but he didn't
he was nervous he was shaking he was
shaking little did he know I would have
done anal yeah he fucked up I mean he
fucked up sometimes you just gotta reach
you just gotta go for it you know what I
mean you never know but let me would you
have I feel like I've never kissed
anyone on a first date really
oh yeah I would have boned him whatever
really oh yeah
easily you kidding me because I go back
and forth you know I mean why not mm-hmm
but why he was a gentleman we we he just
he did everything right you know we we
didn't even our phone his phone didn't
even have text on it so we didn't even
text when we first dated it was awesome
it was all calls we call each other at
night after work school it was done I
feel like I we never had neither neither
had um dating at like it was before
sexting like we didn't it's just like so
pure it was no like it was old school
relation beginning of relationships it's
like Hi how are you doing yeah what are
you doing well damn okay I want to hear
about this coming everywhere all right
we're going back to it so Brett how long
did it take for you to come this fast
with Brett
did it did it coincide with you starting
to make money
no
I have a theory that it's e because
having an orgasm as a woman you can have
no worries and you know that like oh
trust me when it has worries he's enough
you want a worried guy to fuck you
because he'll try harder I mean you
can't have worries
I have worries so that ain't it
um
did you come the first time y'all fucked
no oh no no no no I was like oh I'm
coming faked it you did you ever tell
him you faked it
because when I go back home he goes so I
heard and I say okay it was a bit I was
now you're saying I like yeah
sometimes because oh she said oh yeah
yeah
shit
I thought it was clear because she
didn't have it I'm gonna paint my pants
well no you're not wearing pants you're
wearing shorts that's my shorts oh my
God showed up purple
uh oh God but wait I don't know so you
you can't I I'm at a point where if I
fake it I I can't respect the guy I'm
like you bought that like I can't do it
yeah it's hard to read the LIE when
you're in the dark
and you're just making noises but it's
easy to fake in the beginning because
they don't know how you actually come
because
the first time you didn't tell it was
different when that pussy starts
pulsating oh I made the open life this
is what I said
this is that pussy
where was I
do you want me to tell you how I made up
the LIE yeah we started separate podcast
with Paige called where was I yeah where
am I oh where am I what was I on you
fate nobody still reads the lies because
oh this is you're still faking here we
go here we go let me laugh trying to do
it okay you said you trying to remember
that easier than you can remember what
you were just gonna say Fuck hold on
can you fake like you remember what you
were just gonna know what you're talking
about all I know is wait wait wait okay
and then it will come to me okay so the
reason why he is still believing the
lies because when my pussy started
pulsating I said he goes oh that's a new
one and I would and I oh that's three
squares of mushrooms you just handed us
but he said that's a new one he said
that's a new one and I said he's like
were you even coming before and I said
yeah these ones are just like bigger
ones because I love you you're I love
you more but he's but he's thinking okay
so I've been making her come the whole
time but yeah yeah I wasn't here he
wasn't yeah wow dude he's a fan of the
show I hope hope he's listening right
now I'm kidding well he does watch like
all the podcasts I'm on and then are you
guys
so we need to make her the show
interesting yeah when does your web of
live stop well fuck dude it's just like
that's the guy's dream and I got myself
into the live first night but I I've
grown now I've grown and actually I'm
the first night you guys hung out oh for
sure
but I do say no more often now that's
something I've worked on so now like if
a guy doesn't make me come I'm not gonna
be like yeah I can we do fuck other guys
no but I'm just saying in the future if
something ever how long have you been
with Brad six years
is it this still on here have you ever
almost broke up
oh almost probably every day it feels
like it but
um
I'm being truth why aren't you the truth
it's funny oh well
don't look at me I mean do you tell the
truth on these things or no uh I I
vacillate just half ass it maybe I don't
know
how could I sum it up could you sum it
up for me because you know I do tell
Chelsea everything because sometimes I
feel alone so I need to talk to somebody
you need to be married I'm just like six
I'm just curious she doesn't want him to
propose okay because she don't want him
she doesn't want to marry him
I don't want to get married at all
okay yeah
thank you so much
because I love bread only because of the
way well she was the one who told me if
you it was if it wasn't this fucking
this woman that works at Enterprise
Janine Johnson Janine Johnson who runs
the Things Remembered in Tuscaloosa I
used to work there Things Remembered yes
no way can you tell the story please
what no okay the story about yeah yeah
no okay no you have to tell it
no why not I just gasoline took they
called oh I because I feel bad okay
better you can let it out you can do a
Penance you can do a release okay well I
mean we've all just had that phase in
life and okay so what I have felt bad
about it for especially now that I'm I
don't say I'm famous but you know now
that I kind of experienced it
okay okay I can see it in that way yeah
you're wearing a Dr Phil shirt like
don't be too serious like we're still
I'll make it quick
I was working at Things Remembered in
North Park Mall in Dallas Texas and slow
nobody ever came in there very slow this
was in Dallas Texas they don't want to
remember anything Adele says this is
Circa
2010 okay maybe 11 but 2010
and it's just in a mall yes got it
Selena Gomez walks in no way with her
Grandpa and at this point she is I mean
famous dating one of the Jones Brothers
like she is it she walks in like oh my
God so nice so nice just awesome
she knew I knew who she was we you know
we took a picture and everything real
quick why is toilet paper in front of
you for her nose okay
burritos I just know this is gonna be a
clip yeah and I know that yeah yeah we
don't have that sponsor so she had she
had um bought like a watch she had me
engraved a box with like and you could
we had these books because she brought a
watch from somewhere else no she bought
it there in store oh this is the best
story Things Remembered sells watches
yeah well
maybe a maybe it was a watch box
so maybe she it was a watch case okay
that's right and I engraved the the box
was great at engraving by the way but
you you but don't you just you do it
with the thing the pan it's like yeah no
machine we did it on a machine but you
put it in there and yeah I love doing it
that's fine but um she came in and she
had and we had these books that you
could pick quotes out of it had like a
love funny like different yeah so she
had picked a love quote and it was just
like a random quote that shit picked
what was that I
I can't even remember I I love being
cheated on with one of Ellen's Brothers
just something I can't even remember
like and anyway so I engraved it for all
this stuff all of them
she leaves she was great
it was I think it was the next day might
have been two but I think it was the
next day
I'm there by myself we always work by
yourself and I get a call from this guy
from a big publication
big
tenzie TMZ
well I don't know what publication means
that I would have said New York Times
he's pretty big
magazine okay yeah yeah they got big
publishing I don't know the difference
so anyway and he he's just oh we heard
Selena Gomez was there yesterday it was
wild because like nobody else was in the
store it was very weird and I was just
like at this point TMZ was like big on
TV and big everybody went to tmz.com and
I'm just saying it's the coolest thing
that they're calling I'm like oh my God
TMZ he's like can you send us the selfie
you took what did she buy how much did
she spend and at this point I'm just
excited oh what did the engraving say
I'm excited spilling it and I was you
know I just don't I would never have
done this now and now also how did they
know I don't know so so I know in your
mind like it's just obviously she
I don't they found out so maybe she I
don't know so I'd give them all the all
this information and it was like up on
the website like an hour later
oh my God and they posted a picture of
her and my face is like this
and I'm like freaking out you can Google
this
right now and I
um I just thought it was the coolest
thing the day after that me and my
manager at work no her stepdad calls
my manager had no clue what you know my
calls and was like bitching my manager
out and nothing happened I didn't get
fired over but he was not happy and she
wasn't happy because it was like oh
Selena Gomez buys love quoted box for a
Jonas brother or something and then I
felt bad because I was like oh I I get
what happened and and I get it now and
I would have never told that story
publicly if you wouldn't y'all wouldn't
made me Selena Gomez went shopping
times you guys learned that uh uh oh no
she picked it up at a jewelry store in
North I think they were just mad that
they found out she bought a watch that
Things Remembered like we told him that
he was Cartier yeah you fucked this up
young sponsor Things Remembered I think
she they must have had me look up how
much she spent because that's on there
too like 141. I was like hold on let me
go look in the books yesterday
148.31 and 31 cents dude you went down
to the scent you did this we're told she
gotta watch
that with the phrase
chat time I love you right now and then
personalize the box with a line from a
Roy croft's love poem I love you not
only for what you are but for what I am
with you you engraved that yeah and it
has the picture of the hey but it's a
picture of me and her on there you can
see a sliver of my face
oh my God yeah
you want to know the most heartbreaking
part of this what look how trusting she
is of you oh I feel like she's beautiful
no so she's like I feel safe here with
this woman in Dallas
Whitney I can't look at it but can I
tell you something I can't look at it
okay
you know how can you take a picture with
a fan and you extra love them because
you know they you're gonna make me cry
just a regular person you're gonna make
me cry look how no I can't look at it
look how hard she's trying to make her
picture good you guys look like that
would be a fucking Myspace photo yeah I
still feel bad about that to this day
and this was 13 years ago I don't even
know and I still to this day feel really
bad about it who are you calling I'm not
calling her do not FaceTime Selena Gomez
no just just say what you just said I'll
send it to her manager no oh why not I
feel really bad for what I did at North
Park Mall 22 years ago
I was wrangled in by some guy that
promised me the world at TMZ okay but to
be fair I think Selena was like 8 16 at
the time I mean
oh I feel horrible to this day about
that I don't think you should I do
you know what you probably did let me be
honest I think when things shit like
that how I bet because of this story
there was a fight with JoJo or whoever
the Jonas was the handsome brother
whatever Nick Jonas and they shouldn't
have been together anyway and you
probably sped up
be breaking yeah
I can live with that you know what I
mean yeah I can lose
that's the thing I remember about this
story well Things Remembered perfect and
you know what I will defend someone to
the Grave if it is an honest mistake
thank you and uh-huh
I make a lot of mistakes but they are
honest and I will stand by that yeah
we've all done some dumb shit oh some
dumb shit but it's those they didn't pay
you no that's weekly used to pay people
oh I I no like this is how we know you
had no
um awareness you did it for out of the
For the Love of the Game for the
coolness that they were calling well
they just asked me no questions let's
share with the world their love yeah
this is a beautiful thing
yeah and I agree you so wait so Nick
Jonas has something you engraved yeah
that's what I said how about that
we need to tag him in this
matter he'll give it back to you I think
we can get it back that's wild yeah I
mean if he's kept it for that long
there's probably not a chance
if you're keeping a piece of jewelry I
love you from the bottom she's dead
serious about this look you're fine I'm
gonna see if we can get this back I my
whole thing now is I just weird missions
weird missions to close a loop Justice
for Shirley Temple is my main focus
right now and then uh you know that Hugh
Hefner he bought in the mausoleum the
grave plot above Marilyn Monroe so he
could be buried like I gotta get her we
gotta get her out of that my OCD
he is he is buried on top of Marilyn
Monroe face down so she is like in a
tomb yeah it's a good fight it's a
biograph yes above ground you know those
above ground things and he had he's had
this plot for decades bought it as soon
as she died I think above her so he
could be buried on top of her
so he got his burial plot just like so
he's like laying on her in the afterlife
like yeah
raping her bones yeah and we're doing
nothing is she laid on her back and
where does he want to be laid on his
stomach he said I want to be on my face
down ooh I know yeah maybe he's trying
to say something like what like maybe I
wanted it up the ass who Hugh maybe the
guy above him just he didn't think about
that did he everything I love him I'm
surprised you haven't been asked to do
Playboy I would do it you should they
did want her to do something right
I made that up
was that in the same conversation about
your allergies no after Hugh Hefner died
I made a Tammy video or I talked about
being in Playboy which was really funny
um that may be what you're thinking
about do you know Amanda Cerny no I love
her she's one of my you guys should do a
thing together hilarious and she'll
teach you how to pose for Playboy yeah
she was like one of the play like that's
she's like amazing at it yeah she can
like give you tips to do it hell yeah
why not oh yeah she's wrong with being
in things now is you just call him out
and you're and and usually like I over
the pandemic I did something with um I'm
just being an idiot like because we all
just needed attention and couldn't get
it um so I was like doing some video
about like I'm gonna do my makeup with
me and it was like a dumb fake contour
and I was like Revlon like sponsor me if
you don't you're dumb and then they
called like a couple days later I'm like
can we do a thing and you're like oh you
just call them out and go like I want to
work with you yeah just Gaslight them a
little bit Yeah bully it's called
bullying oh yeah okay perfect it's like
look you can't get a reservation at a
Linea in Chicago that's how I got my
reservation what'd you do I tagged them
and said hey how do I get a reservation
because I didn't get any emails back I
go I'm taking this public okay I didn't
get I didn't get my I I tried to get a
reservation nobody responded to my
emails I went public emails can we talk
about the other thing you did too oh God
but hold on did the emails come from
Tammy
bangs.com
no it came from my Instagram my
Instagram my new low count Instagram so
I don't have the clout I want to add
because my Instagram got deleted so I
had to start getting back that's the
other thing I had to start fresh so it
came from a you know lower count and
they still hooked me up good people well
I've been texting with the chef and uh
he literally I said uh Chelsea got a
reservation I'm flying to Chicago to see
your show there at the Vic and then
we're getting one and then I said oh
this is who I'm coming with Chelsea Lynn
and then he wrote back haha won't be a
problem yeah she tagged me on a story a
while back about a reservation yeah it
works it works and I don't play publicly
shame I'm not gonna I'm gonna call
anyone out for hugging me too long 20
years ago or rubbing their dick on me in
an elevator but I will call you out if
you will not make me the face of your
campaign right yeah yeah I love that oh
we're gonna go and then look he said
it's about two and a half sorry 2.75
hours what does that mean
yeah this is how you know you're dealing
with fucking genius you say two hours
before the chef it's about 2.75 hours
both give you time to go out before
after let me know if you want to try our
bars two miles away from Millennia maybe
when you when you sit down it's usually
like a three hour dinner so be prepared
to sit I will stand all day stand all
day so I can sit all evening yeah no we
gotta do we gotta like do it uh like we
gotta go in the kitchen yes we gotta do
a mukbang in there I'm so excited okay
I'll plan like a hole yes I only has a
full itinerary I mean if you I don't
know what we're talking about this
restaurant is like it is like world
renowned
um people come from all over the world
and it's hard to get a reservation and
it's been a guest on the podcast guys so
hopefully well yeah yeah if you remember
him grant us um some people say ashes
but it's a Shaw a Shaw Grant a Shaw yeah
Molecular Gastronomy wow I totally think
you have to show up with a Portillo's
hot dog and some deep dish pizza like in
your back pocket that's funny just in
case just in case my man I don't know
dude yeah six stars it's a little fit it
feels bought yeah I love it yeah I mean
I will Portillo's Hot Dog not cat let's
do it oh we'll say like can you make a
hot dog that would be to Portillo's oh
my gosh I can't wait is that rude no no
he just puts his dick between some hot
dog buns
try this dead can we can we
can you make a hot dog
yeah I mean I know you can and I'll I'll
bring a Portillo's just in case could we
do you guys do like deep dish pizza not
that I don't I want obviously the we
want the regular the iconic you know the
things that take like six months to
incubate and make and pickle you know
but yeah Portillo's Hot Dog as well just
in case
marination is key
marination that's what she was saying
like you know well he the the stuff in a
linear they cook for years it's like
mushrooms they've grown and dried it's
like a whole fight it's like a science
it's like a damn I cannot wait I am like
that probably took so much experimenting
I I will cancel the whole I can have him
fly in he would love this experience
cover this with my points he would love
this I will use my points to fly him
first class okay I'll bring I have so
many points on Airlines and you can't
really use them unless it's for
recreation because right because buying
a flight you can write off on your taxes
because business expense so I ca they're
like don't use your points unless it's
for pleasure that I never get to do
anything oh that's until your points go
away so I would like to if you've got
points slowly start luring your husband
flying Greg into places let's do it
let's do it he would love him and a
millennia there's no point of going to
Millennia with that I agree with you
well him and I will sit at a separate
table okay that's without you okay that
is a separate thing I'll be having my 18
course meal I'm fine don't you think
like my thing is like
the best guys to be friends with are
happily married men okay because you
have to worry you know yeah there's no
yeah yeah and then I can be a good
friend of You by taking him off your
plate because he doesn't annoy me she
needs that I see a man you fell in love
with thank you 64 years ago literally
she feels like seriously use that yeah
from you how did he propose
it was actually really sweet of course
it was we had our first date we uh we
went to gosh I don't know we went out to
eat but then but then there by the
college is like this little park and
long story short wait it was like real
late at night we stopped by the park it
only had like you know those just
serious when that happened you're either
getting proposed to or murdered well
this was our first date so we went no no
not our first date it was like our
second or third and we went to this park
and we it was really sweet we did a
couple laps and we're sitting there and
I can tell he's like wanting to kiss me
but he's so nervous he's like shaking so
we do have some labs and we was we
decided to sit down on this bench and
there's like you know those little
monkey bars yeah yeah and he goes well
uh what do you give me if I make it
across the monkey bars and I was like a
blowjob
why can you not like I think here's the
tricky thing about us like like women
they're like yeah I'll suck your dick
all you try I think a lot of guys want
us to be ladies that don't know how to
do that okay yeah yeah no the new guy
I'm dating does not let go is not into
it so I um I said well you just gotta
make it across and we'll see you know so
he goes he gets over there and I can
tell he's so nervous you know and he
he's trying he's trying and he makes it
halfway and Falls oh my gosh oh you know
like you know I guess you'll never know
type of thing so he comes back over to
the bench and he's all nervous I can
tell he's shaking and then when we had
our first kiss right there so then on
the night he proposed we did it up big
and fancy we went to Red Lobster you
knew he was gonna propose no no how long
in
two years later he wanted to uh he goes
let's wait how long how long did to have
sex oh no oh no yes for the first time
and then right after yeah so we go uh we
he goes I want to recreate our first
like that was our first Like official
date besides like watching the movie
anyway he goes I want to recreate that
night I have to watch you fall off the
monkeys well yeah yeah spoiler yeah and
I'm like okay this is sweet we go to Red
Lobster Splurge you know this was like
that was big for us oh we go to Red
Lobster
we go and I have no clue what we're
doing we go back to the park Michael
this is really sweet Greg we make our
laps around we sat down he said the same
thing what do you do if I make it across
the monkey bars Michael you have to see
we redid the whole thing but in that
moment where he comes back and we
supposed to kiss he said close your eyes
and instead of kissing he ate my pussy
okay
instead of kissing you and I do he was
down on one knee with a with a ring on
the it was pretty sweet it was actually
very wearing it right now oh I got fat
as fuck it won't fit anymore
but no I'm kidding one of those rubber
bands go to Things Remembered and get
that shit sized up I'm joking I it's
actually a really nice big rain no you
keep saying actually it was actually
like I believe in Greg about the whole
thing you were a monster I believe
everything he does is wonderful
um where do you get the ring uh Zales
let's do Zales can I tell you when I was
engaged last time I was doing a deal
with Zales I went to them and I was like
I want a ring from you I'll do my whole
do it all up but that didn't pan out
it's a relationship yeah next time next
time yeah yeah you just got you got
plenty of Life to Live yeah you got it
what's the other one Kay Jewelers yeah
it's like like will you marry me okay
okay sure okay okay you got me a ring
from like you know what I mean yeah okay
okay yeah every kiss begins with Kate no
it doesn't around Christmas to Kayla wow
to Kayla is that all you hear
you know they sell a lot of rings you
people just
begins with gay right right yeah a gay
man in an airport bathroom you're
holding them through the wall oh man
yeah that'd be wild if needed I've
always wanted to experience that it just
sucks that we have pussies and like
there's no well they could put little uh
Liquors on the wall yeah they need to
figure that out can I tell you today was
a big day uh my sex robot was had her
hymen broken by Paige
yeah no one has ever touched my robot's
my sex robot's pussy until today
I always felt like I was molesting my
own child well when we came in you're
like she has a pussy and no you said
does she have no you asked you asked you
you're sh you have Fuzzy Math you think
she's got allergies and you're the one
with allergies no project because after
I heard that I was like I need to see it
yeah and then you weren't doing anything
about it you didn't need to see it you
fingered it before you saw it and she
has a butthole she did it I did it too
but we didn't know that she had never
been touched like that before and then
we just went in I think I know I heard
her say no I think that was the
motivation it was like she was like the
I want to say Chris Columbus but yeah it
would be Leif Erickson who did discover
America we're the Leif Erickson of my
robot's virginity yeah or is it like
Adam and Eve
that I remember when I when when you
would do specials on Comedy Central back
in the day you would find out what kind
of comic you are based on the
commercials in your special oh that's
you know still today oh I guess what
you're who sponsors you yeah it's like
do they got ag1 or yeah I remember
watching my special first special first
time I'm like with my Dad we're like I'm
like I'm on Comedy Central look we go
first first break Adam and E Adam and
Eve like a two minute commercial like
there's no like Taco Bell came in yeah
maybe which was like taco pink top I
don't know it still felt yeah yeah yeah
every single one was Adam I was like I
fuck with you guys but like
yeah well I've been seeing you a lot on
commercials ads I'm like there's money
there's money really yeah you're on
you're on everything I'm not the
progressive lady right oh yeah you're
not that's not me yeah you are not flow
I can tell speaking of how do you have
your period again
huh Claudia Johnson yeah they call me
Claudia because I have big clots and I
don't go to the gyno because I'm like
you know what you need to go to the guy
now thank you okay for sure that's
psychotic but however uh June Rayfield
when she came up she does something
called the diva cut it's a cup that
catches it and that overfilled uh-uh no
but then you put it in your garden and
vegetables start making vitamins that
you lack you would love that shit
I wonder if uh people eat the vegetables
and they're just like dude there is a
very famous band singer that I was set
up on a date with and the girl that had
dated him before reached out to me and
was just like FYI he's gonna make you
menstruate in his garden to make the
vitamins you lack and I was like she was
like trying to warn me and I was like
I'm that sounds great I know I was like
I'm moving the date to tonight yeah
because it's like the Apparently if you
put it in soil the nutrients probably
what's the top top song that that band
sings which one what did you say I feel
like like
um I honestly don't even know this is so
sad right it's something like um
what should be like the biggest band of
all time
no I'm very oh I hooked up with Adam
turrets from Counting Crows when I first
was cheer not sexual just hooked up not
sex yeah
looking at mean sex to me so I don't
know what you know what like yeah no we
just like it wasn't even anything really
went to Chili's he did tell me about
Fountain though
called crazy girls that was the most fun
it was like it's like a more of like a
titty bar and the girls are like so fun
and like they always play like you know
90s hip-hop and I was like there playing
pool or something and uh he's like come
over and I was I didn't have a car like
I didn't have anything and um I was like
I don't know if I'm gonna be able to get
there and he was like take Fountain it's
like this like the road in L.A that gets
you everywhere faster no one tells you
like normally you take sunset or Santa
Monica or Melrose and he goes take
fountains so he taught me about that and
then I was like I got there so quickly I
was like I will let you fuck my ass your
friends can fuck me I just got here in
10 minutes well how'd you get there
because you didn't have a car so what
did you do I borrowed a Daewoo from a
ripper what's a day woo okay I had a
little woo as yeah they make like um
what's the thing with headgear disc mans
it's like it's like a car if a car was
like a Sony like a Sony car yep I know
exactly what we were talking about
remember they happened for a second oh
yeah so one wheeler
she was on a unicycle going down
Fountain yeah what the I still don't
know what away like you're gonna do
you're sitting down you're like the most
advanced city in the world everyone's
like if you don't live in New York
you're just fucking loser you go there
these motherfuckers on on one wheel have
you seen these oh yeah I'm like fuck you
guys oh my God New York is like so
thanks to the coolest City and then you
go there and they're just like the dorks
on the like hoverboards they're like
they could Cruise they cruise down uh
the boardwalk in San Diego one oil it's
one wheel literally remember skip-its
wait what was that oh yeah what was the
thing Skip and jump on the moon Boots
the moon no let's skip it let me Skip
it's I loved but there was also one it
was like a ball that was like bouncy and
it had a ringer it looked like a planet
yeah I thought that was the half yoga
ball no Pogo ball Pogo Pogo Stick
I a pogo ball with a ball I had a joke
in my last special about pogo sticks and
how dangerous they are and how you'd
always hurt yourself oh yeah and I
fucked up my ankle so bad doing the bit
about pogo sticks and I had to stop
doing it oh my God that's how dangerous
they are were you couldn't even do the
jokes about them I had to start taping
my ankles
yeah pogo sticks is just like a mom that
couldn't afford an abortion yes or other
toys even that was called a pogo ball
Pogo ball I never had it I don't know
we're like exercising like it was all to
get us to wake up the moon boots or
those boots you would jump in what were
those called uh with the springs on the
bottom that shit was so dangerous I know
what was that can I ask you a question
and then we'll do the um outtakes of the
roast why don't you want to get married
just curious just and there's no
judgment and I feel like I've been like
that oh no judgment I that's fine even
if you do um because you can also just
like do it without signing anything huh
yeah just have a ceremony no or a party
like you can be married like six years
you're basically that's longer than a
lot of marriages I think after 10 years
something happens
yeah I don't think in you think
Tennessee fucking plays that shit it's
only in California
um I would say the reason is because
just everything is kind of fake to me
like I feel like schools are fake
fucking everything's fake so I'm like
sometimes marriage real some tips oh
yeah but here's what I'll say though
signing a paper and you don't have to do
the signing the paper seems just like a
scam most well yeah Mo it depends
because a lot of times it's like you
know it's a scam the other way where
it's like if your loved one is in the
emergency room you can't get back if you
don't you know what I'm saying like shit
like that or getting on insurance
sometimes you can use being married to
scam the scammers yeah yeah well they're
like you know you get a lot more on
taxes but it's like no you get less you
get less taxes and if you sell your
house well that's like capital gains
like you don't pay as many in some
states yeah just you know a lot of a lot
of that I think that it's like I'm with
you I'm like everything's a construct
whatever but I think that we're kind of
at a point because everyone is so it
like marriages marriages end and people
are and people are so against it I think
there's something so fucking cool about
doing it like now that no one does it I
kind of want to do it but when everyone
was into it I was like I don't know yeah
now that it's a figure is there
something you can always get divorced
like who like you know you LegalZoom you
can get divorced in 20 minutes some
people just have like you know kids and
problems and yeah well you get to keep
the TV but I'm taking the refrigerator
you have to start playing the prices
right and shit and but you can do that
ahead of time though you can do shit
ahead of time like a like uh but you're
gonna have to do that anyway if you've
been someone with someone
the breakup's gonna as long as you live
together I argue it's kind of the same
thing oh yeah as long as you live
together and bought stuff together
whether you're married or not you're
still gonna have to go through all that
shit yeah
I took the plunger oh wow maybe needed
it wow maybe he did need it maybe he
just had a big old Honker okay well it
was just like this has shit like the
shit yeah you know what I'm saying I
always throw away the plunger when I
move I'm like you know what I don't even
want to carry that stuff over
like the first time I had a guy over the
guy was gonna blow up the bathroom and
be like where's the plunger and I was
like oh yeah oh he took it that son of a
baby like he thought so but I just feel
like breakups are almost just as hard as
divorces at this point yeah oh yeah the
revenge and whatever but I also think if
you're getting famous like
there's something in him knowing
thinking knowing that everyone else
knows you're taken
do you know what I mean yeah breakups
are hard though because going back to
that you uh then you bring social media
into it and you're like did they delete
the photos of us yet you go check in and
that whole part of it I don't delete
shit you keep all keep it up why not it
happened like it's just so weird to go
back and be like this didn't exist like
it happened like I don't know when
people go back and some people might not
like if you found out that you're the
guy you're with was watching Kitty porn
delete it but if it was like we were in
love for two years
down by Machu Picchu photos okay yeah
just because he's in them yeah well you
date famous people so it might be I
really do what so like where'd you get
that you dated the rock star one day
clock Claudia Garden
oh no it that was what is the fucking
band did you date Jimmy Kimmel um did I
do Jimmy Kimmel no that oh my do I know
who Jimmy Kimmel is she doesn't know who
anybody is that is correct who's who was
it do you want me into the talk show
host who's been married for truly 40
years then wrong person oh Sarah
Silverman dated Jimmy no no no it was do
you do you think that she's this is
gonna hurt when I tell you I'm not
serious how do I break this dude her
name's Whitney who is it right there I'm
in Joan Rivers hologram
can we play um hold on what's the band
it's killing me
um we want to know the famous older 90s
band a list of the
oh I don't even know what they do can
you say it oh I love I feel like they're
a band that goes like
Meet Virginia like not them yeah yeah I
love it you know what I mean it's not
it's like a Sublime oh God he's so hot
rants really maybe it's a lot of
bracelets a lot of bracelets a lot of
v-necks dark heather gray v-necks that
go truly to the belly button a lot of
scarves with tank tops in the summer
yeah big like Russian brand Energy I can
see that linen clam diggers great music
though I don't I didn't know the music
this was my favorite thing actually
about the Marilyn Manson documentary
because of all the whole takedown thing
of him every girl that came forward
against him started with I mean I wasn't
really a fan of his music
um and it's like why do you like yeah
you are you know what I mean they want
to make that clear you got the proof
you're already you don't need to do that
yeah yeah I don't already that's it like
the actors and shit that are getting
like it's like I never liked his he
wasn't funny anyway okay
I'm sorry I still can't get over the
fact that Paige thought you were Sarah
Silverman no I didn't did I I think you
show me a pic you know what I think I
think you have an algorithm like of
thoughts so I said Sarah Silverman an
hour ago so I feel like you're just like
you're catching up you opened a file
cabinet in your brain you never can tell
that's great but then you go like you're
Sarah Silverman's on the brain I don't
have my phone okay well who's some
famous people you've been with dated
I've not dated any famous I did oh I
dated a famous director hmm but not like
I don't date famous normal dudes I did
um literal strangers like you don't I
don't even know you've got to start off
they don't remember who it was I think
it was Arielle Vandenberg I'm thinking I
don't know why you definitely uh she did
she did because she's number five guy no
some host like Jimmy Kimmel no I know
what you mean but she oh no I love her I
love her she um uh one time I had her do
stand up with me at the ice house and
she told a story about how she
like had something with G-Eazy oh but
maybe it wasn't they didn't date I don't
want to start rumors I'm not you with
Things Remembered I'm not you know what
I mean oh that call back but you know
that it I remember these are things I
remember yeah yeah yeah things you
remember but also you can't come to a
store called things remember and you
don't think it's gonna be a permanent I
don't think she's gonna you engraved
something on her Google search I wanted
people to remember the things that
happened there
[Applause]
it's not gonna be forgotten no oh no do
you realize when you guys come I Really
Turn shit out I was like they're staying
in my house I put out stuff I put out
Hydro Flask last night I put out snacks
snacks gifts gave us her room her bed by
the way I had signs for everything to
take the only thing they took were the
joints that was me and then no we were
gonna come back and get everything we
were just leaving it there I know but it
was funny I came back it's like
the only thing that was missing on me
that was a bad look because I even asked
that's why I didn't smoke them until I
said hey are these meant to be on the
table yeah I made sure because I didn't
want to be up here yeah just acting like
they were mine for sure okay so podcast
everywhere we it's it's everywhere we
have a it's every Tuesday the viral
podcast it's me and Paige answer are in
people's calls give it a listen yeah we
and like if you have a question for us
you could call us at
442-77-331 and
um what's the other things you're
supposed to say and we ended up I've
asked you 15 questions and you haven't
answered them today oh shit so you seem
so far away
you just said
you you already said you have bad Vision
I'm not I'm three feet away oh God why
don't you get LASIK
in 2020 you can make a decision of
whether or not you want to be with them
that's funny okay what
what she doesn't know what 20 20 means
what do you mean saw him I think there
is I was already with him like three
years I'm confused
doesn't
dude I'm smoking weed and taking this
mushroom thing I'm like
champagne nothing things I never do
nothing to do
a loss
I'm crying that may be the funniest
thing I've ever witnessed in my life
stories
I was with him in 2020 Whitney it's a
good point
I feel like 20 the term 2020 was
invented way before 2020 was even on the
horizon and once the year 2020 came
around I feel like everything got fucked
up yeah you cannot be here
2020 you're thinking yeah yeah how do
you so what do you do you I feel like
you have a lot of things that I um like
you're like too smart for your own good
kind of per like and it no I think
people that are too smart for their own
good come off like they don't know
anything well yeah because then you
don't have to just put out like a you
know when you're like oh I'm good at
having sex and then you have sex with
that person and then they suck so then
it's kind of like that
or do you together like do you know what
I mean well just if that person was good
at sex with someone else it does depend
for sure because I think when you have
sex with a guy for the first time
they're doing what worked for the last
person yeah that's why communication and
you're like okay I know how your ex
comes if they can take the communication
then that's a great person to be fucking
because then they listen to you but if
they say oh I suck at sex then you have
no expectations
well you know how some people will just
talk low about themselves and because
they don't want people
I don't know I live in Hollywood no one
talks about themselves if you're sitting
there saying I'm such a good actress and
then you show up on set and you just
fucking suck then
you know
I think why would someone hire you if
you weren't good at some point well okay
hold on let me try to come up with
another example
fuck
hold on a second it's hard enough to get
a job when you're a great actress you
think people don't understand right
right oh man that would be a good
analogy because that got me basically
just don't set up high expectations for
yourself or anything really for yourself
well don't don't boast just this is the
least inspiring no you mean to the guy
not for you for the guy
to anybody you are speaking to if I feel
like if you don't boast then then you
come off better to them because they
have no expectations
thank you both
let me use the restroom but okay Far Low
doesn't make you come you just gotta get
up and go if you got to go to the
bathroom you gotta go to the bathroom
I'll be right back let me run to the
bathroom with that question though
setting the bar low
if you finger my robot while you're gone
oh no no she scares me walking past the
hallway I'm not stop saying yeah you
scare her you fingered her without even
introducing yourself imagine seeing this
walk by by the way all I thought she
goes down there and she starts fingering
my robot and just goes this is John this
is a huge hole Yeah the hole was huge
dude it actually is vaginal canals it
was a really tight opening and then it
was what I believe is referred to as
light bulb pussy wow which is when it's
a tight opening and then it opens up
into a cavern
my you know when your eyes start
watering because you have to pee no no
no no no
oh you better hurry
you better run
run honey okay how about in the meantime
we're gonna play a clip from Tammy bangs
which what are we gonna see oh man I
haven't picked a clip yet it's gonna be
a surprise okay it's okay
[Applause]
damn what'd you give her
gave her a multi
she's allergic to vitamin D oopsie
who are we gonna have play the part now
you want me to do it
actually that's not a bad idea and I I
have always wanted to see your pussy so
okay let's do it
here we go I currently have over 35
episodes up unreal so episodes are up go
go watch them I'm in none of them
you will you will be season three that's
gonna be the best what's my in one way
I'm playing I think I should I think if
I what's the character we decided uh we
thought well we thought about maybe
um like a a very famous
um
she's always been the funniest porn she
doesn't know you know when you meet like
a like a pretty girl who um use you know
has only had male attention and she
thinks she's really funny okay and
you're like oh and you hang out and
you're like I don't want to fuck you so
I don't have to like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah guys look at your jokes because
they want to fuck you that's great so
you think you're hilarious so she might
think she's hilarious and then she did
like an IG live and was like IG live you
know what I mean what's her name
um it needs to be um
psychology is a famous porn star yeah
yeah we already have a candy
we have a a candy and a Britney porn
stars love let's do like but I like that
she kind of like got big because she
didn't go that route
she kept it very prophetic or she was
like my thing is like
I'm uh
business like I'm not candy I'm not a
little girl I'm like an adult maybe
she's more of like a dominatrix type oh
yeah and this I like because she's a
star and she's used to running her own
sets and then she kind of stands up to
she's like oh we're not doing it that
way and you're like oh I like that and
then your employees start kind of
listening to her
um I'm yes and then Tammy bangs has to
like I come in the dominatrix bitch in
her place yep you have to out Dom the
Dom I like that
maybe it's just drug her though that's
true maybe you're like I just got this
cocaine and it's right all right you
like you laced the cocaine with fentanyl
oh my oh no not to kill her just to
scare just and they're just entire out
of it yeah she went to a dark and then
uh you have to go to like some drug
dealers and be like how do I lace
cocaine with fentanyl just to oh I just
need to I need to I needed overdose and
then I need to save her life
oh damn yeah I mean it's gonna be a deep
episode
we're talking about Tammy bangs you feel
better honeys
oh yeah
all right shall we yeah we're gonna
let's we're gonna play a different clip
right now you poisoned the entire staff
with
ginkgo biloba and
oysters Knowing damn well candy has a
shellfish allergy
for me baby I do everything for you
Daryl listen I know I haven't been
telling you I love you much lately or
showing you but I've been busy running
an Empire I know I have this anxious
attachment style where I need to be
reassured every now and again baby I do
love you okay but you can't be poisoning
the staff look at them I know they're in
love can't you tell it it's beautiful
how long does this last oh about six
hours you can wear off any minute now
you want me to wax your balls in the
editing room to show you how much I love
you I didn't think you would ask I can't
wait come on baby how did everybody like
that love Dad thank you honey it's the
best replacement we're gonna end on
playing some outtakes from the roast
these are things I don't even know what
Pat cobbled together here these are
things that we cut from the roast right
jokes we cut for whatever reason in a
way yeah okay okay there was a couple
that yeah we're gonna watch a couple
fuck you okay so this is okay so Donnell
it was his birthday we didn't find out
Donnell Rawlings it was his birthday the
day we did the rose did not know can you
start from the top top yeah uh so I we
brought him out a cake that said instead
of uh I'm rich bitch which is what he
said on Chevelle show I'm old bitch and
then I had such a hard time controlling
the fucking crowd because I love the
only fans girls love you guys but
they're all the hottest people that they
like skip to the front of the line at
the nightclub So when you say like oh
guys you have to quiet down they're like
she's not talking to us it's all the
people who they were always the except
it was all the exceptions got you you
know people yeah that are like I'm too
hot to like I mean I get to do it you
know yeah and so I was had tell them to
shut up so many times by the time I
tried to lead a happy birthday no one
sang along because everyone was so
energy was off like shout out you guys
are fucking up the sound do not talk
yeah and then so I had to sing happy I
didn't realize no one else was singing
along oh maybe yeah let's kick it off
happy birthday
and no bad added in dogs
[Music]
look at Bert drunk out of his mind over
there Bert is shit-faced so is done up
dude I'm so high I thought people were
really howling
find the crowd I thought everyone that's
the one problem with it is that this
does look like the kind of crowd that uh
would do that yeah
yeah we love you guys we have to go it's
late don't ride elephants we love you oh
hold on can you uh go to eat my trash
come see me on the road I'll leave for
tour in three weeks eat my trash eat my
trash.com
I'll be in Chicago a whole run of
Florida Ohio
um
West Virginia it'll yeah I mean I'm I'm
hitting up everywhere so
um some of them are sold out I don't see
Tammy back Tammy if y'all don't see
trailer trash Tammy in person that you
hate yourself thank you don't miss the
opportunity for real thank you the only
thing that entertains me at this point
besides watching people in videos
propose near bodies of water and
dropping the ring oh in the water yes oh
my gosh thank you honey oh yeah I'm just
gonna I'll just name a couple I'm gonna
put it in post okay
perfect I'm just gonna just come so many
cities come see me and then I'm coming
to see her uh in at the Vic in Chicago
yes you're playing the Vic theater
that's not I'm excited I'm nervous I'm
nervous you always get excited every
time it'll be Chicago Theater it's
always just gonna get bigger and bigger
yeah when you're not staying nervous
you're not girl it means you've
plateaued yeah more so excited it should
always be nerve-wracking yeah yeah
people are paying money to come see you
perform it's so much you know it's crazy
that's normal yeah yeah and people come
watch you it's awesome though they both
Crush I've seen a bowl health and they
both fucking crush it thank you honey
roller skates at Sonic burger oh to the
Vic Theater in Chicago I'm gonna cry you
should that's awesome dude thank you for
having us I had so much fun me too I
feel like we're what a weird are you I
don't even know I feel like we all I
feel like we were filming a podcast I
know it's the best I think it's the wigs
it makes me feel comfortable and then
Whitney's Whitney makes you feel
comfortable because she's so fucking
welcoming
it does affect your inner State oh I
just went and looked in the mirror and
said oh my God
can I tell you something when you need
to negotiate a deal put that shit on
it's changing your life yeah yeah
yes next time we're on I can't stop
you're working better dude I got to yeah
I just don't want to get head lice I had
it for like four years when I was a kid
that looks like big headlights these are
new these are new Ever Had adult life
yes exactly but you know what we all we
have bugs in our eyebrows and our skin
and our eyelashes don't we yeah maybe
like some organs yeah let's go to the
hot tub I love you guys don't write
elephants we love you
[Music]
[Applause]